I pod to know that you know where it was. Ascii. I ask a wife and i up.
And i go on and gram ascii i came from newcastle. Where i was a marine engineer..
And the reason i ended up on the north coast. Was i got busted for smoking. And sacked from the u.k.
And i spent a little bit of time in sydney.
After that which i hated and a friend of mine dropped around one night
and said he just bought a health food restaurant in bangalore and bangle out.
They know the town the back of my mind for years because we travelled up here on holiday shopping.
And i remember a bangle i was just thinking of the little town which is still east. And i wasn't doing anything else.
And so i came up and worked in his restaurant at the time. Was probably the only high strung to the north coast.
It was wind farm and i worked there for about three months.
That was because my friend was why doing a different job was filling in for him.
And then i just heard of a found a house to rent and a playschool bearing about which is the cost of my one on the.
Four dollars a week. And so i went and lived day. And i found on forward into paradise.
There was one other household of people from sydney. Which was the paddington said i referred to before and.
And wonderfully welcome. Welcoming. I'm rural people who offers jobs. Just free food etc.
And at the time that was the time of the holidays catalog everyone had a holiday. Catalog.
And we all thought we were getting away from the big city lot more simple life. Really existence.
Which was totally true. And sisters in this house lead bucolic existence.
Until the dread of the prairie especially my feeling is that the tide was.
We shouldn't tell anyone else and keep it very quiet. Because i could see that. The a.z.
Life we were having would be sort of moral is taken away. Became more popular.
And that's turned out something like that i guess. It's been good to know how i fit in with you claire and paypal.
And the sort of people i like to mix with but.
I don't think i can get a more straightforward and scientific way of looking at things.
I guess that's because my engineering background. But it's all been good fun. At the time it was now.
Judy out there now. And i left melbourne and nine hundred seventy two. Early nine hundred seventy two with my partner.
The time. And my daughter portia. And we decided to go on the road. We sold everything and given away.
All the positions. We've acquired attained a four wheel drive and.
We'd taken about nine months to get from victoria up to the camp to along the way in the mary. River.
For several months and. Explored and we were on our way around australia. We had friends.
Up on the north coast so we decided to call in and say.
One of them happened to be leaving environment where graham was leaving.
The day we driving to mullumbimby was a wonderful day. We drive up into cooper's lane.
And the local alternative people were having.
What we used to have in those days which was about we'd gather together and we'd swap whatever.
We had which ranged from sort of bush knots. Of wild q combos to.
Food or bread that somebody had by your fruit and vegetables of people who peaked.
Close that that bought back from india so you could go shopping at the shop.
With you should parties and all and come home with clothes and fruit and vegetables and. Various things.
And that was a very welcoming. Group of people. And i showed us where we could put up at st.
I asked somebody how difficult it was to find a house. She said well.
It's actually quite difficult you usually have to wait a couple of weeks. Which delighted me and i ended up.
We ended up having a lovely found house there for several months. During that time. People started talking about this.
Gathering that was going to happen and even them. None of us knew when human was it was some way over the mountain.
So one by one we drift.
Most of us knew somebody who was already at an event and then these people had come back over to the coast
and sigh all well it's quite exciting what's happening ivor and human and so on side as they are and they doing this
and that. So we decided sort of collectively that we would go over and join their space to fold.
We gather together a try and.
We were fairly anxious about this festival and we weren't sure how many people were going to descend upon this place.
So we decided to. Range our own little piece of land.
Attached to the main faced a full sized became known as the magic circle and. So we also be able to have a little.
Dwellings. My. Taint was actually the most where the proof. And at one stage of writing.
Just before the festival and i had thirty people in my tent. That put a sort of papal mags. Largely more.
And weatherproof dwellings out of plastic bits and pieces and bamboo and. Various things and.
A few people had taped piece. As the original magic circle and have been settled in all asked to tour.
We'd also set up our own food line way we hired a truck and decided that if.
I mean you can pay for say and if we can still get out
and get up to the brisbane markets to bring back the fresh fruit and vegetables.
This didn't really need to happen because in fact it was very well organized and.
The amount of people little rock same to be the right amount.
It was a very exciting town being named for a few weeks before the face.
Divil just as a few more people drifted in and the constant change that started to happen.
We started off as a couple of hundred people and. As the faced of all got closer you could.
The excitement of the hour now and what was going to happen. Thousands of people going to just saying.
Tains of thousands old mili hundreds.
And that are now an element was very exciting and we had always contingency plans.
And as the face of all just grew it was quite organic and very exciting to just walk around the face to full size
and there was music and a lot of healing and. Various frames of frames turning up and.
Discovering that you were connected and you will lays out the people who will say and you will always other people.
And one of the exciting parts was when the. Feeble foundry bus arrived from melbourne with a cluster of.
Forty or fifty people on board with children and. Musical instruments and beautiful songs.
And also a wonderful skill and knowledge of. Banking hall some. Braid and cakes and so forth.
That took over the local bakery and supplied. The whole fish the whole thing with wonderful goodies. One memory on.
And it's very clear to me. During the festival was.
I was walking down the road from the magic circle towards the area and. And there was doug anthony with his wife.
And doug the leader of the country. And he was dressed in casual country. Do you know. Long socks and shorts.
That he was looking quite relaxed and didn't have any models with it. And i and i both and.
That's just just another example of how tolerant the local people are of dog.
Yeah yeah yeahs one of my memories was just before the festival began and was walking down the road and.
I made two brothers mainly in the seventy's or eighty's it being born in name and and.
Seen for a cup of tea and bread in about an hour and so we walked to dean.
And we probably had very little clouds and i can't remember i think we put her so wrong on
when we actually went out of the magic circle and.
I remember sitting on a veranda looking down on to the faced oval sosh
and talking to these maine about the feelings of. What was happening in a little country town. That was.
That would allow i sure didn't thrill to them. It was lost. They were young paypal.
And their home was being discovered and nurtured and they were very positive about it
but i thought it was a really good thing that was happening. I assume those men and.
Longer alive it's twenty years later but.
It was really lovely to make that connection with paypal who'd been born and sing
and go from quite a lucrative community. To a guying. Town. After the money had gone out of the day every industry.
And i would delight at the young people were discovering their area around to they made it represented law.
We didn't stop and because we weren't living in him and we were living and dying but.
We went back to boring after about three four years of living on. Almost nine money whatsoever.
I decided that i should just get a job and. I worked on. First of all.
On the queensland state government shipped to our stride.
And then later on on the prawn trolls in the gulf of carpentaria and. And that. Moralists ended my connection with the..
Back to the movement. And i had nuff money out of that and. I'm continuing relationship with j.t.
And i are expecting it and. We went totally against the trend again.
On board a hass in dread of delusional and or aspirins living in the hills. Thought we were pricey.
However since then many friends have also been forced to get jobs. And i've also ended up.
Behind houses you know is more. After the faced of all we went back to mullumbimby. But we're still in my jeep.
So we packed at once again and headed for north queensland where we spent six months. That was seventy four. Floods.
And it was very wild up in north queensland you know taint.
So we came back down to bearing with us so i ploughed in one day in front of us
and i saw a clown one day behind us being stopped every. Hundred kilometers boss floods across the road.
It was a very exciting time. Because you kept on making up with the same paper at the same slot and.
I came back to the bering valley and a friend of mine had just moved out of her house and gave her to maine.
We lived there for two years. My daughter went to school and.
I got a little bit of work picking tomatoes for a lot of course and. I by that time had saved enough money.
Through the work. To go to india. Discover debating borders and by that time. I was invited to a monastery. In a poll.
So i took my daughter who was twelve. By that time. To india and we lived in europe for two and a half years.
A bit like graham going to why i brought my connection with the back to the movement.
And while a sword is still a lovely ideal and a lovely way to leave.
Circumstances have changed and travel had changed me. So i came back and.
Worked on the prone troll of with graham for a little while and. That's when we really got together and.
And had a child and lived in lee's mall last year and. Well from maine.
Is very much a place that i couldn't believe in. My have many friends who lives out there. The. The aboriginal stories.
Of a thing as ceremonial place. And not a place. A space. For women to leave.
Is very true and real for me i find it very difficult just to even drive to name and.
Much easier to drive over to the coast. But i have.
I love being close to me and from a sociological point of view it is a wonderful experiment and.
It has really worked on many levels. The levels that it's work gone and not seeing by many people who visit the town.
People tend to focus on the negative aspects of this very small town with no back straights.
So everything happens on the main straight. People assume that's all there is to name and that in fact.
The way that various communities have grown and handle their own problems and become self-sufficient and the way.
That the children are looked after and cade for and the feeling of community.
I think is quite extraordinary and goes faily which may be a good thing maybe that's why it works.
That people are left out in the heels to actually leave out the dream sort out their problems.
They're not a drain on the local economy at all in fact. Die in hansard. And i think in future years.
The communities and even then will be used as a model for many other places.
It's been quite difficult and the level of commitment. Of people.
To leave out their ideals and they drain this is quite extraordinary.
And i can't think of anywhere else in a strange way people have actually achieved as much as some of the communities
around even of achieved. Doritos. And the advent of the human and the title.
And the population that has had quite a profound effect on libel politics.
Manning there are many proposals that are going through a small council which there are now other counts wouldn't even
think about doing. And i guess that's my only because the ideas that are being generated in them.
And there's still a lot of conservatives digging the heels in against it. That.
It will not be continuing
and i think it's to the benefit of lismore castle around memories of being in the magic circle as one of the musicians
in the magic circle was a man called paul joseph and we used to. Sort of a tradition.
Develop their way we'd wake everybody up in the morning by going to just add a little of the wailing
and singing to them and i would sort of a jab they taints and.
In the end they'd be a whole sort of troupe of papal couple of hundred people singing made a long time sunshine upon
you and. Another song about battle flies the poll of britain and it was very. Idealistic very pious.
Piper ish and it was a very lovely way to start the die. A nice way to wake up to the truth.
Very much the truth the door there was also. Wonderful acrobats. Posts and. Hi. Talk right. And cold for labor to.
And he used to do shows in the middle of newman and put up a riper twain. Hotel in the uk and.
With umbrella's on one leg and the children were just. Entranced absolutely entranced as were the adults.
There was another troop of people. From new zealand cold blood. Who were again.
Like wandering means straw paypal i had a big bass.
And i used to put on show on the streets or in town or around the face of all sox.
There was lots of the troubadour feeling later and a lot of freedom for people to express themselves
and to take risks and they create and. There was very little judgement. The children were really safe.
My daughter was about nine at the time and. I remember walking through.
Faced of with her one day and she knew hundreds of paypal and every way we weighed eighty hard polish.
And she just knew everyone from being in this very safe environment for weeks.
And with getting to know people and she'd be fed by the howry krishna.
And she knew sammul people and i did in fact that was true of.
A lot of the children at the time it was a very safe environment and.
I could go off and do exciting things and make movies and. Travel around with musicians and.
There was a great feeling of optimism for the future here in lismore at the moment
and has just become a mother herself. She was growing up into her light. Late twenty's there was.
Some feeling all of why didn't i get to have a normal life.
But as she got older she's by now more to look back
and really appreciate the value of the upbringing that she did has and the freedom and the diversity.
And one of her abilities is to be very tolerant and.
To be able to relate to many many many different sorts of people so.
In fact i think it's helped her to feed into society as it is today. Very easily. I guess traveling overseas.
Help that process as well. It was quite influential for.
Eight has and he needed one of my concerns as she got older as they were responsible and i haven't prepared her for.
University and law yes. But in fact. It's the officers. She's got a great ability to survive well.
Has very clear values about what she wants and what she doesn't want. Yeah i guess it's worked. You know reason why.
Another memory i have of the festival was spending about how a morning up in a tree
and attempting to put into practice another person's ideas.
What sort of shelter you could make with a large flat sheet of plastic.
After several hours and not being able to produce a shelter
or something like the expert says i also eventually made it. I simple. Ridgepole taint which was rather take a bit out.
At the time when the ryans kind of kind of proved to be a perfectly adequate shelter. I think she was rather placed.
Ah yes.
And i also realize that you can only follow the flat sheet of paper long straight lines so that it constructs the model
shapes. That she had in my heart and it was really pretty and practically out that's correct yes.
However the tent that i was staying in was a friend of mine and. It was a path to get adequate shelter.
Because i was a parachute. With a with a plastic conduit framing and to travel was the parachute wasn't waterproofed.
It didn't work so well. I think a lot of ended up in g.t. Stand.
One of the characters i remember in the magic circle was a power to me and character cool i agree and roland and.
I agree and was part of the magic circle one. Did various performances and.
Danced around and told lots of stories and generally added a lot of calla i want to go with the double bill still.
My name is paul and. I used to ride my motorbike from our strides up the coast road and look at byron by.
My mom the indian places like that and i've heard of this retreat. That was set up on quite a few hundred acres.
For gay men. It was called man and. It was run by a man called david johnson. Who was in the theater and.
I guess vegie gardens and. He had a concept that gay men could actually come up here and. Do meditation retreats and.
Do gardening and all sorts of. Alternative ways of looking at their lives and.
So i first came out and went to mend our i think it was the spring. Tend spring retreat and.
It was fantastic we worship the goddess of. Selma and. Selma. Would chant. With selma and chant the full moon now.
And it was. It was a nice experience and. A lot of the retreats that david had with silent retreat.
And so i guess the item was to get to a spiritual high very similar to religious retreats. In a lot of ways.
But in doing so we got really close to one another and. Instead of the humbug rush of the city where you know.
We really didn't get to say. One another personally. This place was great for gay men to go along to and to.
Talk and discuss often sells and to get close to the earth from this would have been in the early eighty's.
Oh yes most definitely. It was an acceptance of men sexuality game in.
Sexuality and it made it a very safe place for us to go and to talk about such things.
And it was a very open many doors for me and i'm sure hundreds of other men.
I don't know how the news got around the planet.
But often we'd go to spring retreats or summer retreats and there'd be men from germany and america
and so it soon become quite global. And it was a wonderful place for men to go to. From all over the world and.
This actual. Country of. Yeah. I'm not too sure how it was fatah's and. But. Word of mouth certainly got around and.
There were lots of different types of things we'd get up to like my paul and.
Hear this chanting the moon up over ten and stuff like that was cool would be allowed so it was one of the first.
Year of. The hippie movement was very accepting.
To guide me to move which was still very young in this country at that age and.
Yeah we felt very well accepted in the community. And. And we also felt as though we could be part of it.
With learning about gardening and. Ways of living in the country without a pushbutton toilet. And without electricity.
So it's good. Good training for us to move to the bush. It gave us the insight that gee we can live like this and.
We can actually dig gardens and. Do without the. Modern side of life. Oh yes.
You know all this more and more i believe got a man moving from melbourne and sydney and. Bruce been to this area.
Because one it's so beautiful and to nimbin people are very very accepting. To us.
And i like the idea of walking arm in arm with my lover.
Down the street and not having abuse yelled out of the car windows or people actually.
Commenting in a negative why are you sure. I've been on tangible now just for twelve months but.
Yeah i admire the people that are there are various there and people are very exception to who i am.
And yet the color is great out there there are people from all over the world. Living then and.
I think that's added to a lot of the color that's there. And the children also aren't little.
Well there's not a lot of little children. A lot by there now there's actually.
Young kids and teenagers that have grown up there.
Of which i've had no trouble with at all when i pick them up on the motorbike or in the car
or with whether they're galloping past on the horses they've always got a smile and. Yeah.
It doesn't seem to be a heavy prejudice coming from their parents.
About who we should be or who we are all don't talk to them.